the prophet Muhammad S.I wasallam told
us whoever builds a mosque for Allah
Allah will build for him a similar house
in jenah and we know the great reward
that will not only be gained but rather
will fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives Shah in the Masid whenever
someone learns something in the Masid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your
scale
[Music]
how are you guys doing I'm joined with a
man who really does need an introduction
you know what we're going to scrap this
right now because this video Yeah is and
needs to be going in a totally different
direction okay you're not going to be
calling the shots okay cuz this video is
where you're going to be reacting to the
people to the people yeah yeah we're
going to we're going to let the people
talk going to let them decide and you're
going to be reacting to the hate
comments tell me okay they've had enough
frankly they've had enough yeah and this
bro if we start doing this we can turn
this into a series I'm serious yeah yeah
series of uh you know with multiple
iterations you know like Spider-Man's
got many generations story tell me read
the comments damn so what are we doing
we're reacting to hate comments yeah
we're reacting to hate comments okay
let's do this thing and we're going to
see let's do this thing here we're going
to see what these people really think
let's see what they it's not this is a
small proportion of people let's be
honest the vast majority of comments are
very overwhelmingly positive cuz they
see me as a hero no comment I'm no doubt
one of the heroes bro they should make a
museum about me bro that museum is going
to be very crap yeah I should I should
throw something give you something so
you can put in the museum of Muhammad
hijab and Ali Da goes to that Museum and
cleans up from time to time
you are a disgusting person Amen to that
brother that joke works because Ali's
right here yeah so he
can all right enough J ja okay go yeah
let's get focused we're going to start
off easy
so quand devious tingle bottom qu 1203
says God Saves turn to
Jesus
before it's too
late what have you got to say to this
guy I
say I say listen this is this is very
typical of you know this kind of
preaching Christian preaching bro you
make the assertion you don't bring the
evidence I'm not interested when people
read that do you think people are say
you know what do you think people are
going to say yeah I'm going to become a
Christian now is that what you think I
can guarantee you that's not uh what
happens okay so I'm not interested in
you and all that comment and you can
leave these comments because I don't see
them as threatening uh to me or to the
Muslim
Community comment number
two you're a disgusting
liar this is by this is by Garrett uh vo
is very
cool that was from my wife okay I tell
her
something what's the buz's name is a
Garrett's volay is very
cool listen I mean obviously they're
triggered by my presence but I'll give
them a ticket to the
museum maybe that will be a you can get
the Ali dawa discount Ali five you get
5% discount okay Ali you verify that
discount I didn't hear what he didn't
hear okay next comment yeah
yeah zaharas 5752
says you are
devil I think you should take that
seriously okay you're
devil you're
Shan
I should be the one that's beinging in
your
direction oh I mean so in Ramadan yeah
you're going to be locked
up how's that going to feel yeah it's
going to feel probably how you live your
life on a day-to-day basis oo absolutely
Shackled up and chained up uh absolutely
but by desires the only thing luciferian
yes the only thing luciferian is this
man's ability to write English language
in a grammatically coherent
way only thing devilish is his grammar
oh okay you've gone there yeah yes okay
all right
jdo yes says JD Sports uh SPS now this
one's j d i p o Wy C APAC probably okay
so he goes wow yes imagine living life
by a man wrote
book are you sure it was a man that
wrote that comment and not a boy because
it seems like it's uh Elementary level
bro did you ask his pronouns I think you
should apologize this this is the
problem this is why we're making this
video You're assuming people's pronouns
don't talk to me like that
yeah you apologize to you apologize to
it
so imagine living life by a man who
wrote a book so he's referring to the
Quran he's mocking the fact that we as
Muslims live by the book okay the thing
is you're making an assertion that we
obviously don't believe it's a man-made
book we believe this is a book from God
that's what we believe right we believe
that Muhammad s Ali wasallam was given a
revelation by Allah the creator of the
heavens and the Earth he was given
evidences and he also given Revelation
we're convinced with the evidences we
are convinced with the fact that he was
a messenger you are living your life by
man-made precepts because if I were to
guess and estimate okay this person's
probably living with some kind of
man-made political ideology or otherwise
so most people are living by the
ideas of other people in fact the Quran
makes mention of
this for
example it's mentioned the Quran you
know um when the when you said to them
come and believe this says they say no
we're going to believe what we our
forefathers
believed you know and then and Abraham
in the Quran he
[Music]
said so what Abraham said is okay well
what if I come to you with something
which is more in guidance than what your
parents came with so in other words
there has to be an Arbiter because all
of us are going to follow our parents or
our societies orever and the Arbiter has
to be the truth in other words we have
to care more about the truth than we do
about following our tribal instincts of
parents culture Society Etc there you go
jdi power Creek lvy Daniel 3815 says
Muhammad I thought you'd be more mature
you disappoint
me you are really childish that was for
me look I mean a lot of people do when
they realize I've got this immit streak
they can be
disappointed but I'm not here to please
you I'm here to live my life and enjoy
my
life and um you know maybe I do need to
take your advice maybe I do need to be
one drum sometimes maybe that's true
what's the next comment that's
right take
that yeah reflect on that yes Mighty
thirsty says thirsty yeah thirsty for
for the champ he says the Quran
recitation this was the Quran recitation
you did yes is so cringe really laugh
Emoji oh my
God I'm going to do that again then is
it isn't it he's caught me now you know
what I mean he's got me now is that it
that's what I have to say is that the
end the Quran recitations now I think I
have to retire he's he's hit the nerve
you hit the nerve uh mighty thirsty he
spel that with a u
thirsty he's trying to yeah that that's
the level he's on yeah see you've done
you've done the job mate this keyboard
Warrior has finally got through to the
real life Warrior true which is
me all
right Matthew Romy 5 63 says this is
amazingly dumb hijab if you don't know
basic philosophy don't debate the
existence of
God he makes a good point I yes if I
don't know it I shouldn't yes yes I mean
what qualifications do you have you
doing a
PhD let's put that to the side that he's
right you know exactly you're not doing
a PhD are
you you know nothing you know
I'm nothing oh I'm nothing but this
12-year-old that's but that Comon he's
11 and a half actually how do you
know
intuition this guy's nothing yeah this
guy's nothing and if you you come to me
and speak to me like that yeah I'll put
you in your place I'll put you in your
place and before he addresses you should
be I don't know why he referred to you
like that he should have referred to you
as the Oxford graduate
Cody Hinkle 7622 says hiab is the
biggest bully and deceiver out
there at least I can succeed in
something if I'm the biggest one that
means I'm the top top guy in the
industry really isn't it that's it in
the industry of deception and bullying
what are you the top guy in hillbilly
mhh what you what are you the top guy in
redneck
whever you are making out with family
members was inbred that's what I'm
saying inbred hillbilly tell me he's got
so much bread could probably start a
bakery
mate ready yeah one more last one then n
who
7777 says hijab got cooked and starts
acting like a little
child sure I don't even know what he's
talking
about I think he's talking about the
David W one oh really yeah let me tell
you something tell tell us something and
this is something they can put in the
hijab Museum MH yes David wood has
engaged with many people you ask David
wood what was your most memorable moment
there's no doubt he's going to mention
the Hammer Hammer ing his
father he's going to mention the champ
oh Piers Morgan has engaged with many
people I'm not going to say the most
memorable moment but you ask the that
boy who was one of your most memorable
moments is's going to mention the
champ you ask for example what's this
Sky Cosmic or anybody who is engaged
with me apus all these ones they're
haunted bro they have group therapy
sessions they do and it's public and the
reason why is
because when I land the one touch the
intellectual one touch on
them if they can't help
but actually it becomes a PTSD for them
they have to remember it
forever this is the reality of the
situation this is the reality of why
this guy whatever his name is is the one
he's commenting on my videos and I'm not
commenting on
his and with that I will
conclude anything else you want to just
let the people know you've heard these
hate comments has this deterred you has
this slowed you down has this weakened
you for those people that do take hate
comments seriously I'll be honest with
you guys I don't I barely even read the
comments and
that's I don't actually read all the
comments I sometimes I flick through and
the the hate comments if it's
constructive criticism and if it's you
if well placed I will I will listen to
that and I will read that and now
feedback is important but if it's stuff
like this I mean definitely it's like
War of the duck's
back it makes me realize The Importance
of Being
controversial and with that guys we'll
see you next time
Salam your brothers and sisters in Islam
net from Norway are establishing a mid a
da Center this Center this Masid this
educational institution will act like a
beacon of light calling the Muslims in
Norway back to the essence of Islam so
give generously and Allah will give you
even
more